[Música]
[Aplausos]
yo no creía en las conspiraciones
pensaba que eran cosas hollywoodienses
como aquello de que el hombre nunca
llegó a la luna o que marilyn fue
asesinada por tener una relación con los
hermanos kennedy sin embargo esto fue
cambiando cuando me dediqué al
periodismo y aún más cuando me
especialicé en el periodismo de
investigación tras más de 10 años de
profesión ahora cuando empieza un
trabajo la verdad que no le pongo
límites no pienso que haya nada que no
sea posible es más si hoy viniese a mi
redacción una persona con una caja llena
de documentos y me dijese que hay una
gran conspiración mundial para callar
los abusos en la iglesia no pensaría que
es mentira
los periodistas del boston globe tampoco
y por eso ganaron un premio pulitzer es
posible que conozcáis esa historia por
la película spotlight que ganó el oscar
en 2016
la primera vez que yo me enfrente a una
investigación con tintes de conspiración
fue en 2012
yo trabajaba en univision la cadena
hispana más importante de eeuu
seguimos el paradero de unas dos mil
armas que los narcotraficantes mexicanos
habían mandado comprar en los estados
fronterizos de eeuu especialmente en
arizona y lo hicieron con la connivencia
de las autoridades americanas porque las
autoridades tenían localizados a muchos
de los compradores y lo que hicieron fue
no detener les y permitir que
adquiriesen las armas y cruzadas en la
frontera con ellas para llevárselas a
los grandes narcos el objetivo era
seguir el rastro hasta los grandes
narcos y esto lo llamaron operación
'rápido y furioso' sin embargo perdieron
el rastro de esas armas y los narcos
acabaron armados hasta los dientes
el equipo periodístico en el que yo
estaba lo que hicimos fue seguir el
rastro de esas armas para ver en qué
crímenes habían sido utilizadas y la
verdad que lo que encontramos fue un
listado de tragedias
por ejemplo recuerdo como algo bastante
duro la matanza de 16 estudiantes
inocentes en ciudad juárez
para poder desvelar esa verdad para
hacer ese reportaje univision invirtió
decenas de miles de euros y un equipo de
dólares en este caso y un equipo de ocho
periodistas estuvimos investigando
durante meses
recuerdo noches en vela cruzando datos
hicimos decenas de entrevistas y
clasificamos y analizamos miles de
documentos yo incluso fui casa por casa
en arizona llamando a las puertas de los
compradores de armas para encontrar
alguna pista
nuestro trabajo formó parte de la
comisión de investigación que abrió el
congreso de los eeuu y salpicó con
fuerza al entonces fiscal general eric
holder nosotros ganamos varios premios
periodísticos por ello
en lo personal yo aprendí que el
periodismo se llama cuarto poder por
algo aprendí porque se llamaba cuarto
poder porque es que sin nosotros no se
hubiese sabido lo que pasó con esas
armas y en qué crímenes acabaron
esa fue la primera vez que tuve una
investigación de este tipo la última fue
en 2018 cuando investiga el sector de
las apuestas aquí en españa hicimos un
programa para telemadrid y conseguimos
la primera entrevista con el director
del juego era la primera entrevista que
daba un medio generalista y la verdad
que esa entrevista por lo que él dijo y
por como lo dijo me hizo pensar que
había más cosas que investigar su
lenguaje gestual creo que se dice muchas
cosas
bueno pues hace poco meses después de
ese programa un equipo de periodistas
tres periodistas de la universidad rey
juan carlos del máster de periodismo de
investigación en el que yo doy clases
hicieron una investigación bajo mi
supervisión y consiguieron verificar
esta información
las patronales de las apuestas pagaron
diez viajes a congresos al director del
juego el director del juego es un alto
cargo del ministerio de hacienda- y
entre sus funciones está el control y la
autorización del juego a nivel estatal
es decir para que lo entendamos todos
que la persona encargada de controlar a
las casas de apuestas ha viajado por
medio mundo pagado por ellas
pues bien esta es la consecuencia de
aquel trabajo
ninguna
yo creo que es un trabajo de todos el
que podamos cambiar esto el que el
periodismo pueda seguir ejerciendo de
contrapoder
de un tiempo a esta parte todos vamos al
supermercado con una preocupación nueva
la de no llevarnos demasiado plástico
hemos aprendido que debemos premiar
aquellos establecimientos que utilizan
menos plástico y que con eso pues
estamos contribuyendo al medio ambiente
la verdad que le dedicamos unos cinco
segundos pero los cinco segundos de
todos son mucho o por ejemplo cuando
compramos ropa por ejemplo nos
preocupamos de que no haya sido
fabricada usando mano de obra esclava es
lo que se llama el consumo responsable
porque creéis que empezaron a cobrar las
bolsas de plástico o porque hay marcas
que creen que tienen que contarnos dónde
y cómo fabrican porque los partidos
políticos empezaron a hacer listas
paritarias porque la ciudadanía se lo
exigimos yo propongo ampliar ese
concepto al consumo responsable de
contenidos porque si seguimos sin pagar
por el periodismo vemos tele basura o
consumimos series que cosifican a la
mujer que nos pasará que seguiremos
llenando nuestras cabezas de plástico
debo deciros que el periodismo de
profundidad el periodismo de
investigación
el periodismo riguroso está pasando por
una época difícil los grandes medios ya
no tienen los ingresos que tenían antes
y están en su mayoría endeudados o en
manos de grandes acreedores y en los
grandes acreedores no les gusta eso de
molestar al poder
los pequeños medios tienen menos
recursos y se enfrentan a dos
situaciones por un lado la tentación del
clic rápido de conseguir audiencia con
clic rápido con esas noticias de no te
vas a creer lo último que ha dicho
donald trump que ha hecho pedro sánchez
y por otro el dilema de molestar porque
si molestas te van a presionar te van a
quitar la publicidad o incluso te van a
echar
de esta manera tenemos la tormenta
perfecta para el poder tenemos unos
medios de comunicación con dificultades
económicas y unas empresas como bancos
constructoras o casas de apuestas con
grandes inversiones en esos medios y de
seguir así va a ser muy difícil que
nuestros hijos e hijas puedan tener
información independiente veraz
pero los contadores de historias también
tenemos mucho trabajo por delante y
debemos encontrar nueva forma nuevas
formas de llegar al público
para mí desde mi punto de vista al
telediario le quedan esos dos
telediarios
pero creo que hoy en día un whatsapp un
videojuego o una ficción pueden ser una
forma perfectamente válida de contar lo
que pasa os voy a poner un ejemplo de
una investigación que terminó en ficción
y lo que esto supuso el trabajo que más
tiempo dedicado en mi carrera fue
investigar al narcotraficante joaquín el
chapo guzmán que hoy está en una cárcel
de nueva york- un trabajo que me llevó
más de 5 años
todo comenzó cuando visitamos este
cementerio los jardines del humaya en
sinaloa la verdad que resulta muy
diciente de una sociedad que el barrio
más lujoso sea el de los muertos
los tentáculos del narcotráfico llegan
hasta ese lugar y cuando nosotros fuimos
el chapo estaba en pleno apogeo para
poder entrar lo hicimos a las seis de la
mañana escondidos en una furgoneta y con
órdenes estrictas de nuestro guía de no
estar más de veinte minutos ninguno de
los operarios del cementerio quiso
hablarnos
pese a esa ley del silencio todas las
dificultades y el peligro logramos hacer
un trabajo del que estoy muy orgulloso
ganamos un premio emmy y marcamos un
hito en el periodismo de investigación
sobre el narcotráfico sin embargo lo más
probable es que muchos de vosotros mucha
de la gente que escuche esta charla no
haya visto o no conozca ese trabajo
periodístico yo soy muy consciente de
que es mucha más la gente que conoce la
vida del chapo guzmán y su poder
corruptor gracias a la serie en la que
trabajamos para netflix
y ese trabajo demuestra que el
periodismo de investigación puede
encontrar nuevas vías para ser más
entretenido y llegar al gran público sin
embargo aún tiene grandes dosis de
ficción y yo creo en un modelo en el que
el periodismo tenga más peso
a mí me parecería maravilloso un modelo
como el de netflix pero para el
periodismo me refiero un modelo que esté
pagado por el consumidor en el que se
premia el trabajo bien hecho y en el que
no se le deba nada a nadie más ese
modelo hoy en día no existe pero entre
todos podemos cambiarlo y ya empieza a
haber algún avanzadilla me refiero a los
medios de pago ya hay periódicos como el
new york times' en eeuu media parte en
francia o info libre aquí en españa que
viven fundamentalmente de sus
suscriptores
lo siguiente sería pensar en el
contenido que consumimos os parece que
debería haber más series que hablen de
diversidad creéis que necesitamos
debates con expertos inteligentes
pausados que nos hagan reflexionar bueno
qué programas veis cuáles comentáis
cuáles compartís en vuestras redes
porque cuando compartes un contenido en
tus redes o lo mandas por whatsapp o
clicas para leer lo estás apoyando ese
trabajo con tu consumo seamos
responsables y no enviemos plástico
hagamos que noticias como la del
director del juego que se fue pagado por
medio mundo por las casas de apuestas a
las que tiene que controlar tengan
consecuencias
si consumido responsable es aquel que
aplica un criterio social a la hora de
consumir para hacer que el mundo sea un
lugar mejor para él y para las futuras
generaciones yo creo que debemos ampliar
ese concepto incluyamos también en ser
consumidores responsables de contenido
a lo largo de mi carrera he aprendido
que las conspiraciones existen y que el
poder va a intentar callar a los medios
que los periodistas debemos ejercer de
contrapoder y debemos hacerlo de una
forma entretenida innovadora y también
que el consumo es la mejor herramienta
de cambio
mi único objetivo hoy es que le
dediquéis a pensar en el contenido que
consumir los mismos cinco segundos que
le dediquéis al plástico cuando vais al
supermercado
piensa antes de compartir una noticia si
ese medio o ese periodista ha demostrado
su credibilidad piensa si hay algún
medio que quieres que siga existiendo y
si puedes suscribirte piensa en castigar
cambiando de canal de plataforma o de
url cuando haya un contenido que no te
gusta piensa cuando veas o recomiende
series películas documentales si
fomentan los valores en los que crees y
piensa cuando haya una noticia que te
indigna cómo puedes hacer que tenga más
repercusión compártela apoya a ese medio
y exige responsabilidades
[Aplausos]
[Música]